move over kids migrants are taking over
your neighborhood football field in
Chicago in favor of a new shelter for
illegal immigrants and residents are
outraged That's The Simple Solution is
no turn the buses around this is what
these kids need for this community we
got violence we got poverty we already
getting scrapped why do we always got to
be at the bottom of the bar I want mayor
Brandon Johnson to understand that
you're selling us out for people who
can't you us you for us you work for us
they're saying wow Chicago Alderman
Chris Talia faroh and Resident Dwayne
truss join us now and Dwayne this hits
really close to home for you because you
coach the youth football team whose
facility has now turned into a migrant
shelter so how is this decision going to
impact the
kids well I was a former coach there
both my sons played there uh with Gerald
Harris who was the director of the Wendy
City football Youth and share program is
going to have a very negative impact
because for 30 years not just Jal Harris
but the people in that Community has
built that park into almost like a
utopian Park that Park is our sanctuary
and the mayor is proposing to take it
away from our children as well as our
senior citizens oh wow so does this mean
that they can't use the football fields
as well Outside Inside facilities locker
rooms explain exactly what's going on
here my understanding is the entire park
will be closed off to the community oh
my and yeah you I mean Sports is such a
positive influence on kids I mean it
gets them off their phones it gets them
uh you know it's a team building thing
it gives them structure so if this
facility goes away that could go away as
well Alderman T Taro uh what can be done
here because you heard from the
residents they said you work for us
we've got violence we've got poverty
we're already getting scraped
why do we always have to be the bottom
of the barrel people are
angry and they have every right to be
angry um you know they're outraged and
and and so am I um I I think our plan of
action um as a community and and from me
as well is to continue to uh implore on
upon our mayor uh to keep this park open
particularly um the track and field
where our kids are playing football and
and we would hope um that the mayor
listens to us and um and and keep the
park open for the residents of the
community it's been very unfortunate um
with so many migrants coming in that U
we do have to shut down a valuable
resource uh such as the Chicago Park
District wow so is this definitely going
to take place Alderman or is this just a
proposal at this point it it is my
understanding after speaking with the
mayor uh that he will do everything uh
that he possibly can to keep uh the
soccer program going and the football
program going uh which will allow our
our youth to utilize the outdoor track
um in football
field but it from my understanding yes
it it is uh something that will happen
very soon New York is running out of
space and so is Chicago and authorities
are bracing for up to 25 buses of around
1,250 people aboard them uh arriving
daily in Chicago you have people
sleeping in ohar airport uh which has
sort of become a migrant shelter in it
of itself if this keeps happening
Alderman what happens to
Chicago we are already at the brink of
not being able to take any more migrants
in uh we're we're closing down our
public spaces in order to accommodate um
the Asylum Seekers um so it's becoming a
very um not to not speak of the
financial um restraint is placing upon
the city
um so we have to make some serious
policy changes in my opinion um and put
this matter out to voters to determine
whether or not we continue and how long
we continue um to be a welcome in
sanctuary City well Dwayne if there's
any sort of silver lining in this it's
that and I believe you uh helped
organize this event where we heard um
all of these residents we played the
clip it was about 600 people that all
joined together and they were speaking
out about this really in support the
community children so tell us about that
event well let me add there was another
600 people waiting outside to get into
the event um that's how passionate
people are about our children our senior
citizens and let's be clear this is not
just about Amison Park this is about all
our parks on the west side of Chicago
where you have the Chargers at Columbus
Park the Gators at uh Garfield Park the
lions at lafallet Park and just because
the kids are going to have access to the
field that field house is valuable and
sense that being able to go in the
locker room in case of uh lightning and
thunder the children use that locker
room to change the cheerleaders use that
Locker in the chain so now you're
talking about having our children out in
the field having to dress and undress
why they can't have the use of their
park that their parents and families are
paying for and our senior citizens not
being able to access that Park you
talking about 30 year plus 30 years plus
residents there and whether the than the
mayor going down to the border to get
take to take a field trip he needs to be
in here in Chicago listening to the
families and the children and the senior
citizens that use our Parks the the
state law dictates parks are for
children and families a it is not used
for zone for a migrant shelter yeah well
the people have spoken and it seems like
their voice is in unison Alderman Dwayne
thank you so much for joining us this
morning we appreciate it important topic
absolutely we reached out to the mayor's
office for a statement but did not
receive a response I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis